[Applaudissements]
il était une fois une petite ville où
les gens étaient comme pris au piège
mais une fille était différente il me
faut vraiment ce job je peux rien y
faire on lui disait qu'elle ne pourrait
jamais partir comment elle s'est enfuie
alors
bien sûr que tu veux fraser
il y avait un jeu
qu'on appelait panique cette année le
gagnant remportera 50000 dollars tous
les ans de nouveaux joueurs s'affrontent
relève de nouveaux défis
tu n'as pas besoin de panique pour aller
à la fac apparemment si tu as tout pour
gagner mais soient prudentes
l'an dernier on a perdu deux gamins à
cause de dieu mais on va trouver le
responsable regardez ça
[Musique]
ça commence
bienvenue dans panique
tout premier défi traverser la manche
l'unss au jeu
paris
chaque joueur a sa propre histoire t'as
jamais par tout le monde a peur de
quelque chose
chaque joueur cache quelque chose toi et
moi on peut gagner ensemble
o o
au
nord je crois qu'il ya un tricheur
ces jeux sont organisés par des juges on
sait pas vraiment qui ils sont
[Musique]
dis moi la vérité pourquoi est ce que tu
veux
il faut savoir de quoi avoir peur
à quel moment avoir peur et savoir faire
la différence
il était une fois une ville bâtie sur
des mensonges
s'il vous plaît
grand nom placed ou qu
il y a encore des endroits sur terre que
l'on connaît moins que l'espace
qu'est ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
où sont les autres
au début ce forage paraît bien ordinaire
mais plus bas vous verrez l'ampleur de
ce que nous avons construit ici
[Musique]
c'est la forme de villa moins étudiée
par la science
ça serait la fin de l'humanité
[Musique]
normalement faire un parc d'attractions
famille c'est sympa balles et cinq qui
tirent la tête là se noue le moral lié
aux occupants 14 ans il vole jogi löw va
dedans moi je faisais pipi ça fait deux
offres ont fait la queue pour toi alors
notre temps tu te rends tu es tu voles
vote dans lé bien ma chérie on va
laisser partir son petit tour de bateau
il ya des moments où on aimerait bien
changer de famille mais faut faire
attention à ce qu'on souhaite vous vous
rendez pas compte en fait on a transféré
nos esprits dans le corps de quelqu'un
d'autre
[Musique]
les quelques
jours à l'hôpital pour accueillir comme
des cobayes sur une table en inox et
fait 6 passes à vos partenaires et
malade avant tout un an j'ai mal au zizi
il est sous gonflés
y avait plus qu'à se cacher et attendre
que ça passe
mais non c'est devenu encore plus
compliqué sérieux c'est dans le corps de
papa maintenant c'est qu'il n'y a pas
mieux
oui c'est ça j'en suis vieille et moche
barbus mais quand je termine aussi avec
toute cette wii fit et bozon dagogo faut
pas s'étonner
il ya quand même quelques son style ph
plan mais quand je dis compliqué mais
bon nous disent ah bah moi c'est pas toi
moi non trois mois et ouais je te
rappelle je t'explique premier
[Musique]
elle fumait elle avait des seringues sur
edit ah non ça c'est normal ça mérite un
chemin bien c'est pour vous sa mère
assise
allez on y va moi je peux plus de ce
corps
on fait deux ans qu une touche plus tu
croyais kouadja interne
à nous
[Musique]
ce fait maintenant deux ans que le
vaisseau amiral est apparue du nez en
envoyant des milliers de drones répandre
le chaos à travers tous les pays du
monde entier
des milliards d'entre nous ont péri mais
la véritable épreuve nous attendait
sa lettre à venir courir ses batteries
se cacher en boucle jusqu'à ce que la
chanson kit oliva
vous comprenez ce que je veux on va
perdre ses caire c'est ça le projet
révol
[Musique]
sai baba
est une supercherie
un
mystérieux virus continue d'éradiquer la
population mondiale attention les
infectés sont très contagieux et
extrêmement dangereux
17h50
il affecté
merci pour ce que vous avez fait plus
personne ne prend ce risque de nos jours
ça fait combien de temps que vous êtes
ici depuis que ça a commencé
où est passé votre famille
salle est
restée mobile ou mourir
la plupart des gens tueraient pour avoir
tout ça
ce ne pourra pas être un paradis pour
toujours
on
n'est pas ici par hasard
abbey
bah ouais j'suis désolé
ben zhang
quand vous devez tous ses serveurs on a
rencontré quelques problèmes avec
l'arrestation de talibans menacent donc
éviter de traîner dans le coin on n'est
pas censé éviter d'y aller
[Musique]
leur montrer qui commande
comment ce genre ici je vois pas
pourquoi je céderai
ici on veut sortir
tant qu'on ferait mieux de laisser
partir
tu préfères protéger ses chiens plutôt
que tes propres collègues
des patients tout ça c'est ta faute
où est mon fils
à force de traiter comme quelqu'un qu'il
n'est pas
on finit par croire qu en laine
[Musique]
chan
c'est juste à côté
da fermer les yeux
rien
[Musique]
c'est clair
papa est ce qu on ira à la pêche on
serait arrivé toi et moi on va la pêche
mon trésor sur eux qu'on soit venu ici
d'être en famille allez bocio commence à
faire froid elle n'est pas à l'intérieur
taylor
elle est où
nous prions le ciel pour que notre fille
taylor nous reviennent bientôt salle et
sauves suis vraiment désolé pour ce qui
est arrivé à votre fils avec l âge
pourquoi vous parler d'elle au passé
la police dit qu'on peut participer aux
recherches cette nuit ici me retiens de
cette diversion pour maîtresse marie la
nôtre
je crois qu'il est temps pour vous et
madame michael sohn d'aller dormir à
l'hôtel il n'est pas question que je
parte tant que ma petite fille n'est pas
revenu près de moi ce n est souvent
on devrait participer à labatut nous
aussi
on prévient la police il sera parti en
3g peintures ont été refaites
[Musique]
au sud du lac ils ont retrouvé la
dépouille d'un campeur
nous sommes théâtre ici
il faut qu'on reste unie face à tout ça
il nous reste plus rien paul témoin ce
qui nous reste sur notre faim
[Musique]
vous devez pas perdre espoir
mais il ne faut pas non plus que vous
restiez coincé
cela vous entraînerait dans un cercle
vicieux
[Musique]
vous verrez nulle part mais tu toi et
toi aussi tu sais que c'est eux qui
l'ont enlevée
[Musique]
je sais qui tu es vraiment je connais
tout et se craignent
pitié chéri
l'acceptation c'est aussi lâché prier
vous n'avez rien de nouveau à dire
[Musique]
une
je cherche ma fiancée
elle était assise là les juniors mes
fils de preston allemann quoi
[Musique]
lui il est du genre déchaînés
à ce moment il était déchaîné
si je tue pas cet animal sanguinaire
pour l'empêcher demi je suis plus là non
[Musique]